you've met the idea of multiple secrets
as early as 10 when you were being an
option because that kind of a hey like
Oh what happens when you have a rap and
you're like okay it's on Factory
what about what happens when it has a
double backed up and what happens when
your hands a so we looked at the
geometry that you're like oh okay a
single word it just comes straight
through the axes a double root it sort
of touches and then it turns around and
then that's a triple a double root right
and then a triple we know it's going to
come up it's gonna pause and then it's
going to talk and then we can have the
language last year off like stationary
points and so on so where do you take
all those informal ideas and we're going
to find they're in a nice open
definition so we can say right you've
got some value alpha and it's a root or
a zero
there's no pause there both of these
words in our context it's anonymous okay
but sometimes you say one or the other
basically agree to call you know tab
visual like I'll be severe cuts the
answers okay where here's this hero is
more hard to break it look you never
need to worry about graphing these
things you can still find a value for
resist because here it has nothing to do
with a picture okay
you gave a real zero of multiplicity and
just like this is about this with one
two or three and those examples are
actually going to be the avenue for
stating a formal definition for this
right the roots or zeros they come from
the factors right so you get rid of zero
or multiplicity and if the factor now
what fact that goes along with the root
is N equals
it's going to be the actual factor the
factor will be something like this or
this or this or this
that's a factor right so I could say I'm
saying it said minus alpha that's actual
factor if that fact that they're chose n
times
okay this is a little bit I went to try
to borrow the language of life prime
factorization and you've got a factor
that comes up multiple times it's still
a factor but it's different kind of
factor right that means different so in
other words you've got some polynomial
and you can run it as a product of that
factor n times which we would write as n
minus alpha to the power N and then you
may have you may or may not have some
other stuff trading along again and
again because I'm going to take my
wolves are going to use say the question
I'm gonna call the other factor okay all
right
now when we first looked at this idea we
didn't know the calculus okay so we're
going to take the calculus ideas and
make sense of this which we just looked
at visually just like we do in 400 now
this is the case what do we know about
the derivative
it's just a product isn't it I mean it's
a product and it's changeable in there
it's not complicated
company if we call this you now we call
it B right let's just go ahead and
differentiate right I'm gonna try three
times you - okay let's do - these
contacts
they are the same okay so this my Venus
why you - cause he is U and V - why
don't even know what Q is some sample
that committee - okay now when you look
at this information should jump out at
you that make sense of this have a look
at it carefully right if I just take a
factor out what factor here yeah I
couldn't take out n minus one of these
factors that are giving me the
multiplicity of this right so if I take
all of them out or as many as I can
which is n minus 1 plane what gets left
in the brackets is let's see well and
what's at this time what gets that drove
up that sign
every one one is a - happened that I
haven't removed and then there will be
few - whatever it happens be waiting
what a thing to notice about this is
everything we've got jumbled up here in
the in the brackets here is just it's
just another function of zip do you
agree with that like everything is still
exempt so this is sand - alpha to the N
minus 1 times some new function concept
there's good pop so what we've just
established if that would give its first
line if Peters ed has a rip an alpha of
multiple ZN that says something about
the derivative and where he has roots
right what does what can we conclude
from this yeah
is
if if alpha is a little off yes yeah
okay almost very close watch out suppose
suppose n were equal to 1 right so it's
going to be a brief there but what's
gonna happen here they were even to one
it's gonna banish the way it's in it
it's gonna happen
Gyan right it's going to disappear when
I be Freddie JB's I'm just going to get
one which isn't right
but what I do know is very close to that
just a little new ones if I have a root
he a multiplicity M then I'll have the
same word for multiplicity and minus one
okay so what that means is for example
how do we understand this has a
multiplicity this has a root of
multiplicity two right that means that I
mean let's just actually look at the
example for you what actually this case
is going to be it's 2x minus 2 so the
really positive C 2 here means the root
of not specific 1 Peter which of course
it counts for the stationary point or
the stationary point that you get the
room and of course you could do the same
thing here right then here the shrivel
group it's going to mean that there is
not only a stationary point there
because this is this but it also means
it's going to be a
whether infection because of all now I
know that we know that this is one
sufficient you have to go and test it we
have to know what's gonna happen in this
case right because everything is
continuous it will be fine
so therefore let's conclude this right
yes if he is in has Zen equals alpha as
a root of multiplicity
and
hey -
we also have that everything everything
everything but the multiplicity will
down break one every time you
differentiate right when you go to the
first derivative then ultimately you do
n minus one and of course if you
different hit again if you can double
dash everything is going to be the same
you still have the same location of the
root but the multiplicity will down
grant will be n minus 2 and so on
okay nothing you need to go very far
like the Federative differentiate the
differentiating sake so this is kind of
where most of the action is happy
yes well so you will keep on getting
roots in the derivatives down to thee
and derivative actually might be the N
minus 1 through it I think it'd be 8
minus 130 because if this is
multiplicity and there by the tiny of
differential pair times it's going to be
0 which is actually not working yet okay
so how are you gonna use this just like
the complex conjugate written here this
is going to save us some time and it's
also going to make some problems into an
impractical perform it would be was
supposed to deal with them so here's an
example